aloha it is me bremen rock and today i
am here with buzzfeed to play truth or
whine
but before we start it let me pour my
mind real quick
who was the best and who was the worst
to film with for
following bram and rod the best would
have to be
filming the show with myself because
hello how can you have following batman
rock without vermin rock
who is the worst film i have to say my
sister
i hate filming anything with my sister
to be honest with you what piece of
content of yours are you
promised of i would say any content that
i filmed
for like commercial ads i really am
obsessed with my kalana ad
anything that i wrote the script for i
would say i'm very most proud of which
piece of content do you wish you could
delete i feel like any content that i
posted
before 2015 i wish i could delete
because
girl i was not even because of anything
it was just because i
hate looking back at that time of my
life and i'm just like wow i was so ugly
i was so ugly anything before 2015.
wait hold on let me drink
i didn't have two but it was calling my
name who was the last elect to slide in
your dm's and what did they say
shall we look oh my god no one dm's me
oh doja cat miss doja
yeah she was wanting to play hotel
highways with me
and um we were just talking about the
game
whose side are you on the james and tati
shane jeffrey saga is there like a i
don't give a [ __ ]
option because i don't
when did you know it was time to end
things girl
what was the last dating app you used
tinder
i actually because i was like definitely
on like grindr for like a little bit
when i was like before my 20s
and then i turned 21 and i was like it's
time to graduate to tinder
and then i did a tinder ad wreck these
beauty influencers from best
to worst jeffree star james charles man
everywhere
i would say the best is me the worst is
also me
drink to that yeah yeah i honestly can't
rank people that i don't know do you
have a finster
or an out of social media account i do
have a vinsta
yes um and i had it since high school
but i don't really like post on it it's
mainly just to stop
period i'm gonna end it there actually
let me take a half a sip for that
because i didn't really feel the answer
what was the dumbest reason you ever got
backlash i could name two the dumbest
reason
is me being gay because obviously i'm
gay like duh
i don't even count that as a backlash
like people are always like haha you gay
duh and another one most recently is my
house
like people really have a problem with
how my house looks there's people always
that things that they're interior
designers can you recreate your iconic
starbucks reaction with
your glass of wine right now yeah
yeah what was it like hanging out with
rihanna and have you guys kept in touch
um no unfortunately we have not kept in
touch
how was it like sweetie it was
definitely life-changing a moment
of my life that i will never forget if
y'all ever see those articles about
written about rihanna and how she smells
good
just know that they have not lied a day
in their life and rihanna actually
smells like heaven
do you have a favorite tick tocker i
have a bunch
actually i mean the gen z generation is
just so crazy and chaotic
and so maybe maybe i could recommend
something rico taquito is really funny
oh this rg guy he is so funny he's
always dancing with his chickens
and i love claire drake and wisdom k
who's the last celeb you texted and can
you read the text oh my gosh okay
yeah i don't know i don't be talking to
celebrities i guess
i don't have any celebrity texts i'll
just drink to that because i don't have
any
what's the most expensive designer item
you've ever purchased
i would say from the top of my head i
would probably say my rolex
i bought that for my 20th birthday have
you ever hooked up with a
fan no i'd like to hook up with like
people
like that fan is not gonna do it for me
all right you guys that is all for the
video i hope you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you guys check out
my newest mtv reality show
titled following bremen rock premiering
on
february 8th monday new episodes every
monday at 4 00 pm
eastern standard time period
[Music]
bye